The thing is, most cars are made with more than one seat.
The problem is that most car owners...
...forget to share these seats on their daily commute.
But if they did, it would reduce traffic by allowing other drivers...
...to leave their cars at home.
And there would still be seat spare for other commuters too,...
...which means that passengers would be able to commute to work...
...in the comfort of a taxi just for their share of the fuel.
And drivers would have their fuel bill covered...
...just for driving to work like they always do.
So how does it work?
Download the Wonder Carpool app via Google Play Store or the App Store.
Sign up, set up your starting point, destination and the time you want to commute...
...and then let the magic happen.
Drivers will be shown passengers heading in their direction...
...and can offer them a ride.
Passengers can request rides from drivers heading on their route.
It's a win-win for drivers and passengers.
One that results in sharing costs,...
...stories and the responsibility of reducing traffic.
And unlike taxi services with carpooling side products,...
...the Wonder Carpool community is dedicated to taking cars off the road.
So if you're serious about building a better future for your children,...
...there is only one option.